Hines Ward former Steeler wide receiver
back on the program
good morning Hines how are you damn good
morning my brother good morning we just
talked about you could have one album
only one album to listen to the rest of
your life that album for you would be
Michael Jackson Thriller thank you
some of the Danites said Prince yeah but
did you ever meet Michael Jackson or
Prince no I know I've never met I wish
that was on my bucket list but no not
happening now but I still listen to that
music every day I get a chance and I
hear their song I turn it up and I do a
little lip sync in the car so people out
there think I'm crazy in the car
sometimes when the music come on here's
a question I had yesterday that people
even ask Ben Roethlisberger about this
with Antonio Brown that people are now
looking at Antonio and saying maybe he's
an MVP candidate one of the top two or
three for MVP candidates if I said that
there's one guy who's the one guy you
can't take away from the Steelers right
now who's the one guy you can't replace
yeah so Antonio realm be an MVP if Ben
is more valuable to his own team mine's
been the things that he's done the ball
you know everyone talks about the great
catches but also I looked at the balls
I've been or throwing I mean they're
right there or only he can get them and
I just think the two together they have
to go hand in hand you can't have one
without the other
and I think a lot of a be opportunities
and some of the balls that he catches I
think a lot comes from Ben
Roethlisberger having trust and having
confidence that I know where he's going
to be I just throw it there I know he's
going to get it so it's hard for me to
sit there and say Antonio Brown when Ben
is lighting it up in the month of
December so
I think they go hand at hand dad what do
you expect out of the Patriots coming
off a loss a bad loss against Miami and
maybe subpar standards that Brady's had
the last three weeks what do you expect
from them going into the game on Sunday
well I expect them to come out to be
focused of course they get grunt coming
back from suspension but it's rare that
you see the New England Patriots lose
two games in a row Dan so I just know
the attention to detail just you know
from special teams defense offensively
they put it all together I just you know
this is for you know the number one seed
it's a very important game for both
sides so I know they're both kind of
trying to have that playoff atmosphere I
can't wait to watch it
he's Hines Ward former Steeler wide
receiver you told me this story I've
told this story to that you got hit in a
Ravens game and you you got hit you got
your bell rung I don't know if Ray Lewis
hit you but you grabbed your ankle
instead of your head yes diving for a
first down he hit me I think we were
wearing I throwback uniforms at the time
so it was actually the first time I
actually wore that helmet that season
and I got my bell rung and all I can
hear is I heard some screaming I heard
ray lewis i heard ed Reed and I was
trying to get up like a dizzy boxer we
got his bell rung and I was good enough
and I wanted to stay in the game so
instead of like you know I try to pull
it off and grab my ankle a my ankle was
hurt but that didn't work work there
they took Roman away and I was out for
the rest of the game what our subs and
Ed Reed and Ray Lewis saying to use your
on the ground part of that rivalry as
always it was a great game last week you
know if I was going to come down to the
last series and and that's what makes
that rivalry so special but do you look
at the Hines Ward rule you do look at
that with pride that that you know
that's this crack back block that that
you're not allowed to do that you made
it
illegal how do you feel about that you
know what I feel about don't get mad at
me or the guys that are doing it get mad
at your coaches so telling you not to be
aware of this guy what he does because
it's still a part of football you know
you can't tap somebody on the shoulder
and be like hey I'm about to hit you
yeah get ready you know it's a part of
the game but I don't think you know I
was there in Cincinnati when juju hit
Berkut and you know I thought it was a
clean hit he lived with his shoulder and
uh you know I didn't agree with him
standing over him but I did it when I
was young as well so you know was young
he's still a rookie in the league you
know now I said earlier later on in my
career I hit Edie Reed and I was calling
for the trainer to come helpful and
overall I was reaching for him but it's
still a part of the game I mean there's
there's not one football player that's
played on that field that has got crap
back on at some point I mean it happens
every play on special team you see a
long pause here you see three or four
guys you crack back but they don't call
it you know it's not illegal in that
sense but it's still a crack back
because the punt return is going the
other way the rest of the team is going
the opposite way so you know I don't
know I take pride in it I guess but
sometimes the Silva game of football I
understand they try to make it safer did
you ever get one of those blindside
blocks where somebody popped you let me
give you our poll question McLovin read
the poll question to hines ward and get
his opinion on this if you were Sam
Donald with Josh Rosen you thought the
Browns might take you at number one
would you go to the Browns go back to
school or publicly say you don't want to
go to Cleveland you know what me being
me up
I would love to take all my challenges I
love challenges I want to be the part
what do you got to lose you're the only
16 for the rest of diseases really you
can't give me any worse than that right
so if you win one game you're the Savior
so if I'm Sam darling I'm up for the
challenge to go to Cleveland see if I
can turn things around
Hines joins us on behalf of on location
experiences you want to give us the
pitch of what you guys are doing and the
Super Bowl tickets that are gonna be
available with this what they're missing
one-stop shop I mean for the Super Bowl
experience if your ultimate NFL fan you
just want to experience everything about
the Super Bowl man go out get your
tickets on NFL on location calm I went
there two years ago in San Francisco I
got up on the DJ booth bad I had a blast
you have some of the great celebrities
the great former players I was hanging
out with Marcus our and it's just a
great experience so you know we're gonna
be at Minnesota hopefully my stiller's
naked I know it's still a nation store
come turn up and we're gonna have a
great time so I'm looking forward to it
log our so you know if you want to get
your tickets going on to NFL on location
comm and sign up for it's a great
experience good to talk to you Hines
hopefully we'll see you in Minnesota
thanks for joining us as always
that's a Hines Ward former Steeler wide
receiver for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]